hello everybody welcome back to our
matplotlib 3d tutorial series in this
tutorial we're going to be talking about
what's called a wireframe but generally
at least for me when I think of a 3d
graph this is the graph that immediately
comes to mind it's the kind of graph
that it's like a it's like a plane but
the plane has like a Hills in it or
something I don't know anyway
if you looked at the thumbnail it's
probably in the thumbnail what I'm
talking about
otherwise stay tuned and you'll be kind
of like excited to see what the heck
this is going to make so let's get to it
from MPL underscore toolkits dot M plot
3d in 4x sees the no difference in
poorer Matt plot lived up 5 plot as PLT
and import numpy as NP the lovely numpy
now if you recall back to the very first
matplotlib 3d tutorial just actually
like for tutorials ago we use the exact
same thing it's it's plot wireframe only
this time we're going to be plotting or
showing you what else you can do with
wireframe so oh with that we're going to
need to identify figure as PLT big here
and then ax equals fig I add underscore
supply 1 1 1 rojack chain equals 3 beads
close and so on
so that hasn't really changed and for
anybody who might be getting irritated
with the fact that pretty much all of
this never changes I still kind of think
that it's pretty important that you go
through this kind of stuff and like redo
it retype it in that so you kind of get
used to it you kind of memorize how to
set up all your kinds of plots and stuff
like that so I think it's helpful if you
don't think it's helpful I'm sorry
anyway continuing on what we're going to
do is we're actually just going to go in
some data for this because these plots
like if you can imagine that the the
first tutorial that we made was very
basic right it only had like five plots
to it but what we're trying to do is
make one of these like fancy plain plots
and it's got like a ton of data so I'm
not about to sit here and just type out
the data for you guys I don't expect you
guys to do that either so what we're
going to do is use something that's
built in to UM this numpy for the air
actually I think it's built into axis 3d
that's right they've got like this thing
where you can get the test data and so
what I'm going to do is copy and let's
just I'm just going to comment it up
here just so you can see what you're
doing when you're pulling this test data
let's see just copy and paste it over
here so this is define get test data and
exFAT let's just let me just do that
real quick so you can read it it's
always going to do is just going to take
from matplotlib m lab it's going to
import this bivariate normal thing and
basically it's going to generate a
really attractive looking um data set
for XY and z so let me just comment this
out again if you want to check it out oh
shoot I wish I could think of where this
hold on you should be able to just go to
like your Python directory since it
might depend on you know what your
operating system is and where you've
installed Python but I would just search
like get test data and you'll find out
where it is if you want to look more
into it if you haven't already looked
through a lot of those files you it
would behoove you to do it because
there's all kinds of good information
that you can find just that's like it
ittan file is already installed on your
machine you didn't even know they were
there anyway so that's going to be our
test data so moving right along let me
make some space all right next thing we
want to do is go X X Y Z is going to
equal X YZ 3d get underscore test
underscore data and generally they're a
little
Delta 4 this is you what do they use
point of five I think yeah so to say
Delta point oh five and then what we're
going to do is come down here now what
you want to say is well it's pretty
simple stuff plot underscore wireframe
and what if we want to plot we want to
plot XYZ and we want it now and then
you've got two other variables that
we're going to throw at you guys
you've got our stride and we're going to
say equals five I guess and then
Seastrom equals one net rr5 sorry hmm
now the purpose of this and actually
let's make this 10 to start just so I
can give you guys a forewarning
um yeah that'll work
and as far as our stride and delta is
concerned I'm going to explain both of
those visually for you guys it's kind of
like the bar charts I think it helps a
lot to think of it visually so our
stride is going to be how often are we
going to just draw a line and then this
number the Delta change is how often are
we going to compute a line two very
different things so let's just save this
and let's run the version that we have
now so this is what it's going to be
generated for you guys very basic 3d
wireframe plot as you can see it's it
looks actually pretty darn good with the
variables we've set so far so the first
thing I'd like to do is let's change our
delta to 1.05 quite a drastic change now
as you can see the computed it's very
not only do we hardly have anything what
little stuff we do have it's very jagged
II right it's not a curved prettiness
now so let's just revert back to the
zero point oh five save that and now
we're back to these well we'll render so
we can see where we are this is where we
are now and then let's edit our stride
and see sure let's make it five
save that will render that and now we've
got it's looking a little bit more
detailed but honestly that the curve
hasn't changed too much now the next
thing what if we wanted to get a little
crazy up in here and we want one and one
now if you don't have a very fast
computer and you hate lag or something I
don't suggest doing this but I'm going
to go ahead and do it so here we go zoom
it in and now we've got this like wow
that looks good now just to give you
guys an idea let's see you know if I can
make it big how much stuff we could fit
in this tutorial video screen that I've
made for us let's do something like that
and so now it's like this huge huge one
now let's pull up let me see if I
okay so here's my processor and in fact
let me let me figure out what I want to
do bump this over a little bit this over
a little bit and so like as you move it
since it's like every time you move the
chart it's got a like render the chart
inah so if you have kind of a slow
processor or something like that at
least for me it's only bumping up you
know a couple percentages but as you can
see when I stop it's like it goes right
like right back down to like 4% and 3%
stuff but uh anyway so if you have like
if you've got like a slow ish processor
you might not want to do it and I'm not
really sure I would expect that this
actually uses your GPU more than your
processor and I've I don't really know
how you can view like your GPU stuff but
anyway if you got a slow computer it's
probably not a good idea to put ones in
there I don't even know about like let's
brawn 0.01 see what happens
render that bad boy oh oh you can only
have an integer so sorry guys so that's
the lowest you can go is one but anyway
pretty cool stuff
if you have the data to fill it now I
don't not everybody has data that's
going to make that oh it's very angry at
me because I didn't actually generate a
plot anyway not everybody has that kind
of data to fill but if you did and you
really wanted to make something like
that it's kind of useful to know exactly
what you're using to fill it and
do it you're actually plotting just
wireframe but do take note that you're
basically doing 3d rendering now
especially if you make your stride small
enough but oh let me do one more thing
let's make the stride like 10 just so
you can kind of see what I'm talking
about so now you can see that you know
one direction there are like it's like
going this way you see there's just as
many lines but going down you can see
that that we've made it stride you know
that's a lot thicker right looks like we
yeah 10 was what we chose so as you can
see now you've gotten our start at 10
and actually it makes it a lot easier to
squiggle this thing around before with 1
in 1 it was horribly hard but now that's
not so bad
anyway that's going to depend on again
your processor and I really think your
GPU but like I said I don't really know
what kind of resources it takes from
your GPU because I don't have you if
somebody just had a view it I've been
kind of curious to see how how heavy
this is on my GPU so anyway that's going
to conclude this tutorial this tutorial
this tutorial as always thanks for
watching thank you for your support your
subscriptions and so next time